all right so
we're going to cover a lot of ground
and ultimately we want to talk about
real quick but we're doing some
comparative work at first and then you
know so that you guys
can easily anchor this you know in your
your own
profession that you're training for
we're going to look at balloons
letters to a young chef and
focus on a few passages from from that
and then we're going to have sort of a
palette cleanser with with a bit of
poetry
vibrant so you can get some some idea of
what he's like and then the rest is
going to be a little bit of comparing
balut and then roll kev on the rest will
be all going in deep into rilka as deep
as we can
in the lecture so let's start off by
thinking about these
these guys um if you had to
if you couldn't say chef what would you
say
what is teaching teacher okay
that's interesting uh
how would you capture that he's about
food
i mean it's just how you just said
earlier that food
is a you know language to everybody and
everybody can relate to it
okay so let's say
teacher
food
dishes
teacher of food knowledge
knowledge
and maybe let's use the word vocabulary
if you have the right vocabulary you can
communicate with anybody right
real good again you can't call him a
poet what would you say
well a life coach interesting
now that's a profession that didn't
exist in his time
of course it's very recent uh but you
could see what he's doing it's sort of
like life coaching
even even professional coaching to a
certain degree
yeah the master of solitary and personal
explorations
okay let's actually
explorations that's that's exactly right
a matter of fact this term solitary
we're going to look at what he means by
solitude
he says it so many times yeah and he's
got a very specific
idea in mind of what that is hitchens um
you know maybe from the reading
selection you don't know
as much about him um
you can call him a contrarian if you
want yeah i was going to say he's a
master of deconstructing ideas
okay that's a good way to put it
deconstructing
i'm going to put up another term that we
often use in academia along with that
and gene mythologizing
ideas movements
institutions
even people you know once once you got
in
hitchens sites he was pretty tenacious
the little passage that you do have he
talks about going after
bhagwan sriran sheesh and that's
somebody from when i was a kid
he was this uh this religious leader
and he was like you know he was known
for having this incredible stable of
rolls royces
at the same time he was preaching
poverty and austerity and things like
that and hitchens
there were he wasn't the only person to
expose him the irs actually exposed him
but uh hitchens was was in on it so
um why read
these these three guys and then can
compare and contrast them
kitchens was just put in there by way of
contrast to these other two
he probably has less less in common with
balut
and and ryoka um
what are these guys doing by doing these
letters to a young
xyz what sort of activity are they
involved in
yeah mandatory okay it could be
mentoring
uh rilke is sort of like a mentor to
this guy well
um i mean you could imagine yourself
being mentored by them it's not quite as
personal exposing exposing what
secrets uh well each of them are
exposing like different things
i guess secrets kind of secrets okay
of
he is yeah he's telling you things that
you wouldn't ordinarily know yeah
uh our first journal entry we had to
write about
what we would tell a culinary student
after we graduated like
an incoming one like to help them out
things like that it's pretty much like
that's what they are doing for each
particular
area that they're passing on how to make
the insides to help
each other out okay yeah that's
they're kind of exposing themselves and
setting up the arena to talk about
like that it's the ideal arena to
proclaim
your work to someone yeah there's
actually a certain vulnerability to it
one thing is you could in fact come
across as arrogant
but just by giving advice to somebody
that never bothered pitchings for one
thing but
um and rilka might actually
you know that would be something they'd
have to overcome um
you are putting yourself out there balut
is using himself as an example over and
over again
um is to a certain extent in these as
well
so you're right now
there were a few other things i wanted
to sort of point out in this they're all
trying to
help out a new practitioner in the field
with tensions you gotta wonder
what's the practitioner supposed to be
the smart you know smart guy
or just uh and it's the person who like
raises problems all the time
you know what is what is the purpose of
that
is it just to be a jerk yeah maybe just
saying
if you're going to do one thing don't
confront yourself or
just don't make yourself like dumb kind
of don't make yourself a what
look dumb just by doing the exact
opposite of what you're saying you're
doing
just like how he said
you don't need any of these things to
live a lavish life
yet he had a collection of rolls royce
yeah and he was saying
uh girls would sniff
sniff for alcohol and drugs
at the door yeah he wanted you to have
an open mind but there was a sign that
said leave your mind and shoes at the
door
and he wanted you to go in pretty much
as a lab rat so he could pick your mind
and he can make you think these things
without you having your own saying yeah
the bodybuilding free-range pieces
ashram was was in fact sort of a mind
control cult
hitchens says um
if you care about the points of
agreement and civility that you'd better
be equipped with points of
argument and combativity and he's saying
that
in part because he thinks that we need
to be armed so that we're not taken
advantage of
and that we're actually doing a good
thing by fighting with people
sometimes at least you know they the
truth doesn't always win out it takes
people actually standing up for it
he says homer actually got things wrong
heraclitus said strife
is actually a good thing strife
conflict argument that's something that
we actually
need so that's that's what hitchens was
driving at that's you know there's
there's some sort of good for each one
of these or set of goods that they're
proposing
as important for for the people that are
reading them all three of these are
actually very modern
as well
you know the loot is he tells you he's
part of a
tradition that goes back to the 18th
century
but he's reflecting on what it is to be
a chef in the 21st century
of course is reflecting anything in the
21st century because he's at the
beginning of the
20th century but he's thinking about
what poetry
needs to be like and he revolutionized
poetry yeah
i was just gonna say like even i didn't
even know when it was written
honestly because i wasn't looking at the
dates but i would have never known it
was written back then because he made
like valid points that could like
be like discussed today well they're
timeless yeah
yeah um when it comes to these sorts of
things they they
you can tell something's not very good
if it has an expiration date
you know a used by date kitchens is um
you know he's very recent as well we
talked about
dying fairly recently and he was
involved in a lot of debates you know
the debate about
the iraq war for example he played a
major role in that
a number of other debates as well all
three of them are
are expressing a perspective on their
profession or their field but they're
also
sort of situating it within a larger
perspective on the big questions
that's why i you know i'm a philosopher
that's why i'm interested in milka
because he's actually
addressing the big questions things
about the nature of the self
what is a human being how should human
beings
be connected with each other what's
nature is there
is there a god he talks about that in
there these are all
sort of key ideas that they're they're
working with
the only other thing that we'll look at
from this this compare and contrast
thing
um the ideas that you did
find interesting you talked about real
quality the idea
you found an interesting blessing in in
or if you found something interesting in
hitchens
why did that jump out at you what was it
that impressed itself upon you
yeah with the chance he was like
really blunt about it like you're saying
like he's just
like he's not he calls someone out
without caring
and like he's like we'll back up your
information if like
if you are what you say or then why
can't you back it up a number of you've
talked about oneness as being assertive
really he's like he talks about it in
like a sarcastic way like
he's like stating facts but he's saying
it in a way like
oh yeah well like just a sarcastic
kind of way of explaining it
okay yeah i think the thing that
resonates the most with me about
all three of them would be just their
honesty about everything that they're
saying
like how they keep calling it blood but
i would call it one i would call it
honest
why would you so how would you make that
distinction
um because they all have valid
explanations for the things that they
are saying they're not just pulling
random
random things out there's there's a
reason and a rhyme for every word that
they're using
and the specific order that they're
using they are all masters of language
that's that's for certain
you had your hand up there but never
mind okay so
four is yours in all three works i feel
like
the writer instills a sense of optimism
and um they encourage the
whoever they're writing to they
encourage them to
um proclaim their individuality sort of
and to explore themselves rather than
saying like this is what you should do
they say
you know this is what i did and this is
you know well
except for hitchens he doesn't really do
that he just deconstructs things but
he doesn't in other words but um but
they're encouraging you to
define yourself and so you walk away
with a sense of like well maybe i can do
something
yeah that's a good way to put it there
there is an optimism inherent in
thinking you can
actually have some control over your
your destiny but
what you need you know this goes back to
like why are they getting advice
in order to actually have control over
your destiny in order to be able to make
informed choices
you need to know some things and that's
what the older
person is trying to pass on to the
younger person
let's look now specifically at that
belief
i have a number of passages that um
can you pass that down that we can look
at
so the first one
he says spending six months to a year at
each station since just about enough if
you practice
keep improving and keep challenging
yourself to make it perfect
the more you look at cooking the more
you realize it is always an unfinished
education
there's truly no limit to how much you
can learn
and i think you guys are you know
becoming painfully aware of that
as you go through your classes right i
have a similar experience every time i
go to the library
and i walk through the stacks i used to
get depressed because i would say
man i'm not even going to like read my
way through this stack
before i die and look at how many more
there are i'm never going to know
everything but you don't actually have
to know everything
in order to have a good life in order to
do well in your
your profession but there is a sort of
endlessness to it and this is part of
what keeps us humble
when we think that we know everything
that's when we get into trouble
we think that our way of doing things is
the the only
right way or only possible way then
we're not going to be the
creative ones what do you think about
this one where he says
my advice to you is remember your
grandmother's food i know a lot of you
have this this text and you've probably
read that
um it doesn't have to be your
grandmother for example it was a good
cook
you know your uncle could be them too he
says grandmother's a short way of saying
remember the foods that connect you to
your region your family or culture
it's like proof that it's madeline he's
talking about proust he was this
novelist and he wrote the the uh the
search
or the the quest for lost time
oh you're doing it okay so you guys know
about proust and the madeline inviting
into it having this
incredible flood of memory so he's
french of course he thinks everyone
knows about this
um because in french schools they do you
know you get plenty of proofs
so he says once you start thinking of
one famous famous dish from your
childhood it sums up
the whole world not just dishes
but all the other things that go along
with it right all those other memories
you're talking about you know the
melange of
your your friend the poet and trying to
read realty at the same time
that's a natural human thing to start
blurring these together
when you're a chef you're going to want
to honor your past by transforming food
memories
into offerings that belong in a great
restaurant so now
not all chefs think that do that
there's plenty you would say you need to
leave whatever
hick thing you you know are bringing to
the the proverbial table behind so you
can learn
the classic tradition or you know the
modern modernist stuff but
is talking about embracing your own your
own past
yeah i was just going to bring up matt
said it
a while i forgot what dish you're
talking about but what
he has like a dish that's in his family
and he brought it to the restaurant that
he works with
now and he had it on the menu oh
good completely i know it was pretty bad
oh i was saying how like in the
restaurant that you work in you
brought like one of the dishes that's
like your family said that
when i was younger my dad always made
chicken and dolphins bowling
chicken with the big chunks of
vegetables and one way i required it was
the memory i got with any friend of my
family together
we knew dad was making that because we
couldn't wait and he weren't there when
he was served
he didn't get any because they didn't
last and then one thing i did was
um i'm gonna i brought a shelf of a golf
course to kingston where i work
and uh i would i got that on the menu
just as a special and the thing i loved
that the best was when i presented it
and served it to
older people or people my age they all
got that same feeling that i got
that wow this is how their grandmother
used to make it or this is how their
parents used to make it it made me feel
good because i could from my food memory
to them
and bring out their food memories and
having the same thing throughout their
family
yeah that was a great thing for me and i
use that the whole time
to astronomy and i base it off memory
that's actually a good one it brings up
another one of the passages
the very bottom one on that page it says
perfectly roasted chicken tastes the
same way at my restaurant and then he
names a couple others
what makes each different is what makes
one painter one author different from
another the soul of the artist he says
i mean this in the direct senses i don't
mean a new agey sort of thing
i mean this in the direct sense that the
food has to give you a feeling of
well-being
that's sort of what you're describing it
needs to make you happy
yes the technique must be perfect
meticulous and precise yes it must amaze
you
but it must also make you happy and in
order to understand that you have to
reflect a bit on the nature of happiness
and you know there's plenty of other
classes for doing that so we're not
going to try to do that with that here
but you get a little bit of that with
the aristotle stuff because
yeah yeah you haven't done it yet okay
okay well you will be doing something
like that
there's a few other ones in here that
are important as well
notice how he how he ties together
culinary arts with the arts the mozart
you know he says as restaurants
developed the culture developed with
them cuisine
held a rank alongside theater and other
arts
the result was a public that would pay
the price for oak cuisine and challenge
their chefs to new heights of creativity
french and he's you know touting his own
heritage here right
the french took dining part of daily
life raised into an art embedded in high
culture
thereby attracted economic resources
cultures make choices for their
definitive statements the italians
lavished everything on developing their
opera
the russians their ballet the french
chose oak cuisine and oak couture they
made
this into an art form uh
you know you know you notice that he
brings up poetry he brings up
all these connections he says that you
don't just want to be out there tasting
food
you want to be out there actually
watching ballet because you might get
some ideas
from that you want to be out there
experiencing
things that other people have found
beautiful
because that's you know one of the
things that i i sort of want to sound
you out about
with baloo is thinking about this
question how is a chef
different from a cook and i'm not just
looking for the answers that he gives
but you know they're good starting
points
i think a chef understands food instead
of just cooking it
it understands how it all comes together
how it comes together
yeah i mean couldn't a cook understand
what they're
they understand what they're doing
certainly yeah they don't really know
the background is the line
i feel like once you the why that's the
one with the food and you know why the
things happen
yeah keep going
no no i think you have to form a
relationship between your food and
you
the chef and the cook both do cook
so they're both involved in the same
activity the chef as you said
understands the why and cook understands
the what or the
the that and the chef understands that
as well you can't be a good
chef without being a good cook right but
the chef takes on that responsibility
they take on
expressing their knowledge through their
cook so that their food gets put out the
way they want
why they believe is right okay
i'm gonna put another r word here
response
which again will make more sense when
you get to aristotle the chef engages in
responsibility
and rule they run things to be
responsible means to actually say
this is the way things are gonna get
done the cook
you know follows
nothing wrong with following as a matter
of fact if you want to be a chef
you have to actually do a lot of
following because that's part of how you
acquire your your technical expertise
and as aerosol says you can't actually
lead well unless you follow it well so
you you need to do some of that
as well um well luke talks about a
number of
other things he also talks about the
difference between
hungry chefs as he puts it ambitious
chefs
and then the chefs that are just you
know i just need to you know
get a job and that's that's that um yeah
averages average isn't enough
that's a good way to put it they don't
just want to not be average though he
actually talks about
first the person wants to get a job
then eventually they want to work their
way up to be sous chef and then they
want to be chef and then they don't just
want to be a chef they want to be a
restaurateur and they want to open in
multiple restaurants maybe
average doesn't stand out the average
doesn't stick out if you
just do an average you just get five and
you do
above and beyond things you kind of do
differently
yeah he talks about a number of ways to
do that different modalities how you
should do service well
how to think about wine and desserts
well
he also talks a lot about your education
as a
burgeoning chef as well doesn't he he
gives you advice about
travel how to eat during that time
um one of the other things what's that
one of the other things i particularly
like about this
is this is a guy who is actually asking
you a lot of questions
if you read between the lines he's
saying a lot of things in declarative
terms
and in imperative terms he's giving you
commands almost
but that's typical chef sort of thing
chefs don't always ask you
questions they throw something out there
on the table i say
what do you think and then it's up to
you to figure out what you're going to
do with it
he's actually opening up philosophical
questions for you
what is the good life how do you in fact
hone your skill
how should you be directing yourself
notice the second to the last one that i
have in here so the bottom line is this
is actually from the selection that
professor shaka
had you read for this one the bottom
line is the only way you'll advance in
this profession is if you invest your
own time over and above the time on the
clock
the same is true for orchestra
conductors race car drivers law
professors and ballerinas
every profession that draws ambitious
dreamers
demands time so two things there
one well three things really i mean you
may not have you know
gotten the connection until you pointed
out you're kind of like a race car
driver
or a ballerina uh here we go
or law professors orchestra conductors
we could we could run down the line
all sorts of architects
all these are people who don't want to
be averaged they want
to do something interesting
they want they're motivated by their
their subject just like you guys are
motivated by food
you're here because you love food you
also want to get a good job and
you know learn all sorts of things you
actually do love food because if you
don't you
get the hell out of here right you don't
look like you don't actually love food
now notice what he calls uh chefs
ambitious dreamers
ambitious okay i think everybody can
relate to that because a lot of students
come in i want to have my own restaurant
are you dreamers yeah
yeah you think that if you're not a
dreamer you can't be as creative as
you can push yourself to
so creativity is also part of being a
chef that goes back to the
issue of bad richness and originality as
well
that's something else that distinguishes
shot from premier cooks
now notice what he says about time it's
something where you
can't count the cost you can't do it out
of schedule
it flows over schedules the people who
make it
who really you know succeed are the
people who are driven
to go beyond the the time clock
and there's you know there's different
motives that people have for doing that
sometimes
people begin with the motive i need to
always be at the top but it really turns
out it's because mom and dad
were always you know coming down on them
if they didn't get the best grades or
something like that
that actually won't last through your
life
likewise you know wanting to be better
than other people
wanting to tell other people what to do
those will sustain you longer than just
satisfying mom and dad
but they're ultimately not not that
satisfying
um so what could provide a motive
for what could actually provide
something that would be sustainable
or you know when you're 40 50 60 years
old
so you're actually going to still be
happy with your profession i think that
you always need to remember that
you're a cook first and meaning you're
always a student so you
can learn something new every day even
if you're about what
well those who surround you about the
ones that you teach
how you can become better and you know
the food that you
eat at somewhere out in another
restaurant or
anything in general
all of these their desires provoked
by the phenomenon of food you have to be
in love with food
in order to remain a shop because you
can you know you can get the degree and
you can get a position
but if you don't actually love your
subject matter in the way that it keeps
drawing you in
you know the curious person is always in
everybody's business they always want to
find out
what that guy over there is doing but
not because they want to be better than
him
or one up her or anything like that
it's because they actually love that
thing and they want to know more about
the thing that they love
it's the same way with with anything
else that you're going to study yeah
is it not like passion you want to make
yourself better
you want to be you want it to come out
the best it can be
yes now notice um
he talks a lot about that doesn't he
about perfection
perfection isn't you know some sort of
state that you can actually reach it's
this
he talks about consistency and the the
only thing that's better than
consistency is that it's better the next
time
right he says at one point and
you're right
so did you say like the desire of
perfection so it's like you can't really
reach like perfection it would just be
designed
well there's there's that's a good
question there are different ways to
desire perfection
there's uh the desire for perfection
that becomes perfectionism and that will
kill you
especially as a chef it kills i see
students struggling with it just trying
out papers or things like that
perfectionism will keep you from getting
things done it will keep you from taking
satisfaction of what we do
and you need that to sustain you over
time
that that stems from less of desire in
terms of
the object itself and more in terms of
pleasing others
we're thinking about one's own
self-image things along those lines it
really
talks about one second i think that in
that sense
competition comes in because you're
always trying to
there's you're trying to be better than
everybody else but you always try to
better yourself
you know you're competing against
yourself
yeah and there is the the aiming at
perfection the desire for
perfection has in i need to be a little
bit better each time
that's sustainable that's doable
and that's motivated to take your
criteria
from what it is that you actually love
not from yourself
not from you know whether 100 people go
to your restaurant or only one person
goes to your restaurant
you take it from the object itself
that's that's difficult to do it's hard
to
it's harder to stick to that than it is
to you know look to
other people but he is saying something
like that um
that's pretty much all i have to say
about about uh welluda at this point
let's look now at these real kids can
you send around the poems
realtor wrote a lot offs and i picked
two
one of them the translation is by robert
fly and i don't remember who the other
one is
is by um if you really want i can read
you the
german as well but we don't necessarily
need to do that
but he is much yeah were his letters
originally in german as well
he is um his poetry is better in german
he wrote some of his poetry in french
too
later on um it's hard to capture the
robustness of his his language in
translating
but this is a pretty good translation
let's look at the i love the dark hours
of my being
i love the dark hours of my being my
mind deepens into them
there i can find as in old letters the
days of my life
already lived and held like a legend and
understood
then the knowing comes i can open to
another life
that's wide and timeless
so i am sometimes like a tree rustling
over a grave site and making real the
dream
of the one its living roots embrace a
dream once lost among
sorrows and songs
now with the poem it's not you know it's
not an expository piece of writing it's
not about
just getting to the heart of it
immediately these are the sort of things
you have to kind of linger over
and allow to work upon you
this is a beautiful poem and it
expresses something about
something we see in the letters
something about
the dark recesses within ourselves in
memory
he talks a lot about childhood in this
respect as well
but notice he says i can open to another
life
that's wide and timeless
by going inward we often think that when
we go inward we're like
going away from everybody else and we're
kind of shrinking in
and there's not not a lot in there
rilka says it's actually sort of
expanding
we genuinely go in not just going inward
by like saying
screw all of you yeah or um
you know i don't really know if i want
to hang out with these people you know
that that's not the sort of inwardness
that he's talking about
but actually just sort of think i i'm
gonna hang out with myself for a while
and think about things we open ourselves
to a life
he doesn't say necessarily we get a life
we open ourselves to a life
that is wide and timeless
we have a greater freedom greater
possibility look at the next one
this is a very famous poem by welcome
it's been translated many many times
just as the winged energy of delight
carried you over many chasms early on
now raise the daringly imagined arch
holding up the astonishing bridges
miracle doesn't lie only in the amazing
living through and defeat of danger
miracles become miracles in the clear
achievement
that is earned to work with things
is not hubris when building the
association beyond words
denser and denser the pattern becomes
being carried along
is not enough take your well-disciplined
strengths and stretch them between two
opposing poles
because inside human beings is where god
learns
there's a lot going on there i'll just
mention just a
few points that you might relate to your
own
experience look at that third stanza to
work with things is not
hubris uh mitsubirican is nikki to
literally
arrogance raising yourself above things
when building the association beyond
words
now think about what it is that you guys
actually
do think about how hard it is to
describe the tastes of things in words
you are some of the people that real gay
is writing this poem in
reference to when you're putting
together a dish
you're engaging in the sort of thing
that he's he's talking about
food is we have words for food who it is
to a certain extent
beyond words denser and denser the
pattern
becomes he actually says
more inward the wet becomes
think about the act of cooking as the
ingredients are coming together
and you're going to do it over and over
and over again you've already done it
over and over and over again
sometimes throwing away the dish
oftentimes serving it
often to your fellow students that's
what he's describing here
now this could be cooking this could be
child raising
this could be teaching this could be
working with soil it could be a number
of
different things take your
well-disciplined strengths and stretch
them between two opposing poles
because inside human beings is where god
learns
what do you think it means to take your
well-disciplined strengths your powers
and stretch them between two opposing
poles
literally between two contradictions
this goes back to the thing about that
what the hell is that
any ideas yeah i mean i think if you
related to kitchen it would be kind of
like
supreme fine dining and you know a diner
a diner yeah you're putting out food but
it's two
complete different streams so what does
that mean though to stretch your
your powers your strengths between those
like work in one and then working the
other
i mean you would have to put out good
food either way
even though one is not as expensive you
always want to put out
good quality food whether it's a diner
or a really fancy restaurant
you know that's a good point um that
actually reminds me of something i'm
thinking about about
i do a lot of public speaking and
sometimes you know just a few people
show up sometimes you have
tons of people show up and
it's one of the temptations is to say oh
only a few people showed up
so therefore the event was no good you
know
but if you're actually involved in
communication if you're offering food
say
you know with care i don't even
necessarily love but just
care about the person you're offering
into there's a personal connection
and you have to treat even if only one
person shows up
it has to be worthwhile to serve that
one person
and to provide them with just you know
instead of saying
man i'm not going to give you the real
lecture i'm just going to give you the
dumbed down
one um no you would actually just like
you know you're saying
serve the the real meal
just as you would if 100 people showed
up or just as you would if a chef showed
up
one of your shelf instructors came to
your restaurant can you imagine that
that might be a nightmare right
you know i i can't imagine the chefs
that i know
when they would actually come to a
restaurant like criticizing a student
like that like they would in the
classroom
yeah he says he doesn't criticize yeah
in school so he gets it out of his
system
that's good so
can you see how these poems connect with
with your own
working life your own education
there's there's a lot of other there's a
lot of other poems that may not connect
with it but
i picked the ones that i thought would
actually hook up with the best with you
but i encourage you to read rilka's
poetry
when we're looking at his his uh
letters to a young poet it helps to know
what the guy's actually writing in comic
poetry
now think about how rilka and balloon
are similar
in their advice what are some points of
continuity
i'm going to erase this what are some
points of continuity between two of them
because we're talking about two very
different things aren't they
food and poetry and okay maybe food is
kind of like poetry but
what points of similarity are there in
their advice
that you saw yeah they're both like
he's trying to look back at like uh your
culture
food and stuff and yes
in poetry he's saying that he's like
don't write about fiction first he's
like right about your actual
life first like so go back to like your
life to write about first don't worry
about like non-fiction first
i'm gonna
your childhood is if you want to write
you've already got enough
material with your childhood if you're
really opposed
if you're really a chef with the food
that you've tasted thus far
if you were never going to be allowed to
learn any new recipes
you have enough things that you could
modify those recipes and come up with a
whole bunch of meals if you're really an
artist in the way that he's talking
about
no that doesn't mean you're stunned
i don't want you to say well how old i
don't need to go to the culinary anymore
dr sandler said go ahead i was going to
bring up another point um
mentioned something in one of one of the
letters that
think about think about poetry and think
about writing poetry and think about
if you can survive without writing
poetry because if you can survive
without culture you
should not be writing poetry and value
kind of feels the same way about
food if you feel like you can survive
without being a chef then you shouldn't
be a chef like you should live and
breathe whatever industry you're in
whether it be the poetry industry or the
food industry yeah because you know it's
a lot of sacrifices
is there such a thing as a poetry
industry yes
unfortunately most of the products are
very bad what's that
i was like just follow dream because
wouldn't that just fall into the
umbrella of writing
uh yeah i mean there's you know there's
a whole bunch of
journals that people write in and you
can take classes on it
like published right now and you can you
know if you if you
get people to believe in you you can
offer workshops
and teach other people how to write
poetry and
i've been to some of those and
afterwards i'm like man i could have
done that
but you know maybe i didn't deal with
the right people
sort of like you know maybe you've had
the experience with certain cooking
things
or like whole neck i don't learn oh yeah
yeah i didn't learn anything from that i
could have taught that class
well that's that's probably a sign that
you're further advanced right
but you're right is there a necessity an
internal necessity
now when rilke talks about necessity he
means something
like is there a necessity
inside you what he calls
a fate is it your destiny to be a poet
if not then hell don't don't bother
because
it's a hard racket if you don't have a
destiny to be a chef then you know why
bother with that
that's that's setting yourself up for a
lot of grief you know better to get
you know an easy job just like to add on
to that like
um if you're like a chef then you're
giving up a lot of your time
and same thing with you saying like
poetry like you he's like
um be solitary and take time for
yourself and get away from everyone
and be alone so it takes time it's not
like
it's just like you writing down like you
have to go with it
and write down like what you feel and
stuff so you have to
it's going to take a lot of time yep
and if you're always counting the costs
if you're looking for the trade-off
you're probably going to be unhappy
you know think about the amount of time
you have to put in
just you know you guys it's almost like
thinking about medical school
with chefs because first you go and you
you
do your your your education
then you got to do these and you do this
sometimes during your education i know
but
these unpaid internships and they're not
ordinary internships going to get coffee
for people in some business office it's
working your butt off in somebody's hot
kitchen
with people yelling at you all right and
then what happens
that now you're fit to like now you can
go in at the bottom level
and now you have more people yelling at
you right but you're used to it now so
it's not so bad
and then you might work your way up but
it's going to take a lot of
you know skills and things aligning the
right way
and you have to have what we call
perseverance in order to do it
that requires that you make a commitment
without counting the cost because if you
actually tally up the costs
you're going to say i'm crazy but what
am i doing
medical school is like that too first
you do four years of undergraduate and
then
medical school and then your internship
and then you know residency and
uh which is basically like being on
stage
for years
and then you're you're actually a doctor
with
300 grand of a debt then you get to
start your practice
with no clients and it just goes on like
that if you were actually to like think
about that in those sort of terms
nobody would ever be a doctor you become
a doctor because you have a
passion for what you're doing same thing
by the way for college professors
if you really thought about what you
were doing you wouldn't do it
you know thought too hard about it you
know
yeah um like well going back to that
it's just how he says i can open to
another life that's white and timeless
i think with someone that writes poetry
they can put their soul into it so you
can put yourself in their shoes
they speak so vividly that you can put
yourself in the story
and with us cooking food you put your
soul into the food
that you can actually feel what the
person is feeling when you were cooking
okay
so there's a product and as you say your
soul goes into it
who you are not just it's not a purely
external
relationship to the thing yeah i mean if
you were going to write
if you're going to write poetry it's not
actually going to be like an expression
of
something you feel you have to write why
bother writing it then
you know there's enough poetry out there
already
it's not like it's not like food where
it goes bad
and you guys need to keep on cooking it
you know
unless people actually need to write
poetry probably that we should have a
moratorium on people writing their
culture
um because we have all this this piled
up stuff to digest
whereas you know you guys every time you
make a work of art it's there just for
this brief moment
and then the diners demolish it
and then hopefully it's retained in
their their memory longer
than it is in their stomachs let's look
now at
these you're right these are all points
of continuity between these
these thinkers let's look at rilka and
some of these key themes
um and how are we doing on time
i'm just gonna type you a little note
okay
we have until five after seven so we
have 17 minutes
okay let's look at the biggest
theme then and we'll see what else we
can get our way through
if there's one word
that this text is about it's solitude
you see him mention that
in letters 1
3 6 8 10 and there's some sustained
discussions about
it in each one there's little references
to it in nearly every one of the other
letters as well so when we see this term
solitude
our temptation is to think just in terms
of like
being alone maybe also loneliness
withdrawal
real could mean something a little bit
different you do have to withdraw
yourself
but um solitude is something
creative and productive for him so we
want to get our head around what what
what
the hell is that you know what does he
mean by that so let's
look actually this is a good way to do
this sort of work let's first look at
what he says
and then we'll see if we can correlate
these different things
so he says in the first letter um
go into yourself that's going into your
solitude
find out the reason et cetera et cetera
and he says dig into yourself for a deep
answer
if this answer rings out an ascent if
you if you meet this solemn question
with a strong simple i must then build
your life in accordance with that
necessity that's part of what we just
talked about
and then he gives advice about um you
know not writing love poems not trying
to do
the same sort of things he says try to
raise up the sunken feelings of this
enormous
past of your childhood your personality
will go stronger
your solitude will expand
and become a place where you can live in
the twilight
so i'm just going to jot things down
without actually commenting on them
your solitude is a place where you can
live
where the noise of other people passes
by far in the distance
so that means it's not actually going
away from people
um he says after this descent into
yourself and your solitude maybe then
you have to renounce being a public
that's a risk so solitude is kind of a
you know dangerous place to go to this
maybe why some people don't like to go
there
and he says um even if
even if you don't want to become a poet
this won't have been for nothing
your life will still find its own paths
from there and that they may be good
rich and wide is what i wish for you
more than i can say so solitude
is
solitude is good for all of us he's
saying not just
not just poets
actually i promise too i would talk
about the
capital things so
says that things have their own
interiority as well
this maybe goes to some of the things
about
plants animals everything has its own
interiority its own faces to show us
but we have to be attentive to them and
then they can impinge upon us
if we're tied up with ourselves
if we're focused on you know the
busyness of the everyday we'll miss it
and what things are going to impinge
upon you are you know
very contingent and they may not be the
same things that impinge upon me
you know nature for example i grew up in
southeast wisconsin
and so i may have a different
relationship to granite than you do i
don't know where you grew up
but we had a lot of them and it was
usually pretty weathered
that could be a thing in roca's terms
we can have an affective relationship to
it
food ingredients
fine wines those could be things
in the sense that milk is talking about
does that give it a bit more
yeah they kind of have their own
solitude
we have to work on our on ours
um let's look at letter three
he talks about solitude again and there
and he says uh
works of art are of an infinite solitude
that's a kind of strange thing to say so
you know
think about van gogh's daughter
everybody's seen prints of that right
um so that art
hanging so then the loop i don't know
somewhere obviously at some museum
it's hanging somewhere right um that
work has an
infinite solitude uh that doesn't mean
that it's you know away from the other
paintings it means that it contains an
entire world
could culinary
creations have that sort of
infinite solitude that's that's
something to think about
this is where he's actually saying don't
don't think about criticism
as uh the way to approach these he says
only love can touch and hold them and be
fair to them
always trust your own yourself and your
own feelings as opposed to argumentation
discussions or introductions of that
sort
if it turns out you're wrong the natural
growth of your inner life
solitude is a place where our inner life
can grow
that may guide you to other insights it
takes time
for that for that to occur allow your
judgments their own silent
undisturbed development like all
progress must come
from deep within and cannot be forced or
hastened
he says being an artist means not
numbering and counting but ripening like
a tree
it only comes to those who are patient
who are there as if eternity lay before
them
unconcernedly silent and vast
now that may not be you know what you
want to hear when you're
young and wanting to get things done
and you know make your way but he's
saying that you can't really force a lot
of the
the really important insights and
experiences that you're going to have
that you're going to use to make
yourself into something
letter six the ones a lot of you like
letter six because it talks about love
notice what he says about the connection
between love and solitude
he says
that uh
i don't know is that one no it's uh
seven where he talks about that um
so let's actually hit on that he says
it's good to love because love is
difficult
for one human being to love another
human being perhaps the most difficult
task that's been entrusted to us the
ultimate task the final test and proof
the work for which all of their work is
merely preparation
that's why young people who are
beginners in everything are not yet
capable of love
he's not saying totally incapable he
says it's something you have to learn
it's not just something you feel
it's something that you have that has to
grow within you
by the way this doesn't mean that older
people all have it down
you know the divorce rate would not be
you know over 50
if they if they actually had it all down
he thinks that very few people have
have done that he says um
learning time is always a long secluded
time and therefore loving
for a long time ahead and far on to life
is
solitude
well i don't have the same pagination as
you it's the beginning of letter seven
um he says a heightened and deepened
kind of aloneness for the person who
loves
loving does not at first mean merging
surrendering and uniting with another
person
for what would be the union of two
people who are unclarified unfinished
and still incoherent
it's an inducement for the individual to
ripen
to become something in himself to become
a world for the sake of another person
only in this sense has the task of
working on themselves may young people
use the love that's actually given to
them
merging and surrendering and every kind
of communion is not not for them
again you'd probably say looking at most
of our old people it's not for them
either
because they haven't done the work and
you could do this work
through your profession through how you
give yourself to your profession
learning how to to ripen in your your
abilities and your skills
he says but the problem is young people
are so often disastrously wrong
they fling themselves at each other when
love takes hold of them they scatter
themselves in all their messiness
disorder bewilderment and what can
happen then
what can life do with this heap of
half-broken things that they call their
communion
and would like to call their happiness
and their future
it's not going to work imagine a recipe
where you're just sort of throwing
half prepped things together
willy-nilly and you got the heat on
somewhere but you're not
you know is it the right heat
how's the dish going to turn out
yeah who knows um probably not so good
right or you know you're making
something in the blender let's just
throw everything that's what we used to
do
if you know if a little bit of
ingredients is good let's put in more
and then pretty soon everything's brown
and
your taste to it well the same thing
goes for our emotional life
and our way of living so he thinks that
we need to
to so solitude is sort of a
precondition
or real love
we need to learn how to withdraw into
ourselves
um going back to number six he's talking
to this guy
and he says um
you know you're you're bearing your
solitude he's a soldier now he's away at
christmas
you're bearing your solitude more
heavily than usual
but when you notice that it's vast then
you should be happy for what would be a
solitude that was not vast now notice
what he says here
there is only one solitude so when you
are in solitude
you're in the same solitude that i'm in
and we're in the same solitude that
rilke is in
it's not being totally cut off from each
other
it's being reconnected with something
going beyond us
something deeper than us sort of like a
tree you know putting us he loves these
tree metaphors and roots
going into the soil it's vast it's heavy
it's difficult to bear
and almost everyone has hours when you
would gladly exchange it for any kind of
sociability
however trivial or cheap like going on
facebook
or turning on the tv or what else do we
do
go out to the bar right just see if
anybody's there
um but these are the very hours during
which solitude grows
you're posed with an opportunity when
that sort of thing happens
if you invest yourself in solitude and
when he's called solitude
then you can grow you're preparing
yourself for greater growth
we could there's one other thing he says
here too he says
only the individual who's solitary is
placed under the deepest laws like of
like a thing so only the individual
who keeps going back into their
solitariness
can actually experience the world
in its fullness and have a sort of
development come out of them he talks
about you know being
able to accept your fate into yourself
long before it actually blossoms
in i think it's letter eight um
that's the sort of thing that solitude
can afford to us and as the letters go
on
there's more of this talk about solitude
really being this this one big thing
that we're all sort of
bound up in if we can get away from
superficiality
now what would what would this you have
to do this is all very metaphysical
what would this have to do with your
lives as
chefs in training do you need solitude
of that sort
is it merely an emotional thing is it
like you know so
you can keep yourself on track as a
person or would it actually have
anything to do
with your cooking
what do you think yeah i was gonna say
it's
um important to like have solitude
because
like the kitchen could be a stressful
place and like
you'll you'll be like stressed and
overwhelmed and stuff so you just have
to like
take that time to like go within and
like
step back from the situation to like
make sure that you're like
calm and you stay sane
okay yeah that's probably very important
well if for me if i'm going
with the way roko looks at solitude that
it's a place where you can
grow within your experiences in your
past then
you know if you're creating a menu or
creating recipes or creating anything
then you know going within yourself and
looking at
looking at what moves you and what
drives you as a chef and what drives
your past
um is a great place for to create the
imagery that you use in your dishes
yeah i think you're right so you could
serve your
you could serve as like a uh not
not providing you with a palette because
the palette is still kind of crude
um providing you with a storehouse
yeah um i was gonna say kind of like
whenever you're
you're prepping for like your reason
class everybody tends to get into it
they say like oh you're they're in the
zone but that zone can just be a place
of solitude where you are where
the noise of others pass by you and
everyone around you is working and
everything in the kitchen be going crazy
but you're just cutting carrots dicing
shallots like you're just there it's you
you're working you're amazing
and you're just living in there with
your things just doing it they become
things with a capital t
right so that's that's the connection
there yeah
a good area uh time to use solitude i
think is
when you are getting burnt out how are
you saying when you're overwhelmed and
you're
doing it so much that you don't even see
it before you are burnt out and that
last camel or that last straw on the
camel's back
just breaks and that's that one place
that you can go
and that you can look and see reflect
on what you did wrong or what
you need to calm down now notice that it
has to be ready for you
if you're going to go to it though which
means that you have to have drawn
into it and come back out of it before
you get totally burnt down
it could only be there as a resource for
you if you don't wait until you're like
totally frazzled yeah and maybe if you
do it enough you don't get burnt out
you know yeah i think it's just kind of
when
you're second-guessing yourself
sometimes you can second-guess yourself
in the kitchen because you hear
everybody talking about others or maybe
they criticize you
so if you go into your own zen you can
just kind of bring all your ideas
together and bring back that confidence
that you know
so confidence could be yeah that's
interesting
um confidence is
the feeling that we can't actually do
something it goes back to that optimism
somebody had talked about optimism
from you can actually do something about
your
your condition he's offering some
insights at least for this guy
and then you know to us the readers
about how we might improve our lives um
how much time do we have any time we're
it's i mean
at this point it's up to the class how
do we continue
they have one place that they can get
dinner which is k-16 oh i don't want to
keep them from there
so this is we should wrap up okay
so don't have any questions and here
what we could probably do is
collect them and then follow up yeah
yeah or i should have video
yeah uh didn't get through as much real
quick as i would like but uh
hopefully you know as you now you're
better equipped to
sort of see all the connections between
these things
and again remember you don't have to
like real cut or you know
agree with him but but understanding
what he's putting forth can be can be
quite useful
so thanks for your time